[Music]
those who make the worst use of their
time are the first to complain of its
brevity
[Music]
the unnamed should not be mistaken for
the non-existent
[Music]
if poverty is the mother of all crimes
lack of intelligence as their father
[Music]
as favor and riches forsake a man we
discover in him the foolishness they
concealed and which no one perceived
before
[Music]
two persons cannot long be friends if
they cannot forgive each other's little
failings
[Music]
life is a tragedy for those who feel and
a comedy for those who think
[Music]
we are afraid of the old age which we
may never attain
[Music]
most men make use of the first part of
their life to render the last part
miserable
[Music]
the pleasure of criticizing takes away
from us the pleasure of being moved by
some very fine things
[Music]
such a great misfortune not to be able
to be alone
[Music]
a person's worth in this world is
estimated according to the value they
put on themselves
[Music]
generosity lies less in giving much than
in giving at the right moment
to laugh at men of sense as the
privilege of fools
[Music]
if some persons died and others did not
die death would indeed be a terrible
affliction
out of difficulties grow miracles
[Music]
not to be able to bear with all bad
tempered people with whom the world is
crowded shows that a man has not a good
temper himself
the same principle leads us to neglect a
man of merit that induces us to admire a
fool
[Music]
there are only three events in a man's
life
birth life and death he is not conscious
of being born he dies in pain and he
forgets to live
[Music]
the most exquisite pleasure is giving
pleasure to others
[Music]
a man is rich whose income is larger
than his expenses and he is poor if his
expenses are greater than his income
[Music]
grief at the absence of a loved one is
happiness compared to life with a person
one hates
[Music]
time which strengthens friendship
weakens love
[Music]
if it is true that one is poor on
account of all the things one wants the
ambitious and the avaricious language in
extreme poverty
[Music]
a wise man is cured of ambition by
ambition itself his aim is so exalted
that riches office fortune and favor
cannot satisfy him
we can recognize the dawn in the decline
of love by the uneasiness we feel when
alone together
[Music]
the very essence of politeness is to
take care that by our words and actions
we make other people pleased with us as
well as with themselves
[Music]
everything has been said and we are more
than 7 000 years of human thought too
late
one seeks to make the loved one entirely
happy or if that cannot be entirely
wretched
[Music]
that we seldom repent of talking too
little and very often of talking too
much as a maxim that everybody knows and
nobody practices
we keep a special place in our hearts
for people who refuse to be impressed by
us
[Music]
sudden love takes the longest time to be
cured
[Music]
novice exists which does not pretend to
be more or less like some virtue and
which does not take advantage of this
assumed resemblance
[Music]
when a book raises your spirit and
inspires you with noble and manly
thoughts seek for no other test of its
excellence
it is good and made by a good workman
[Music]
as favor and riches forsake a man we
discover in him the foolishness they
concealed and which no one perceived
before
[Music]
if our life is unhappy it is painful to
bear
if it is happy it is horrible to lose
so the one is pretty equal to the other
[Music]
when a woman does not take her eyes off
a man or always takes them away from him
everyone immediately understands what
this means
[Music]
they that have lived a single day have
lived in age
[Music]
there are only two ways of getting on in
the world by one's own industry or by
the stupidity of others
[Music]
we are more sociable and get on better
with people by the heart than the
intellect
we must laugh before we are happy for
fear of dying without having laughed at
all
[Music]
so
[Music]
you